talk to me a little bit about your
future at snl
i know i want to know that's my lesson
from last year
sort of see what happened i'm excited
about the possibilities i guess cecily
talk to me about this
amazing series it caught me off guard i
mean i really i felt like a child
who wants corn pudding
i wanted to sing i wanted to dance talk
to me about why this is the perfect
thing
for everybody to kind of let go of the
last year and jump in
and fully engulf themselves in a musical
series i mean i think
with shmiga doon i've been involved
since about 2018
um and coped had not happened yet and it
still
felt like the perfect thing to share
when a school wants another squirrel
he don't bother to get attacked oh you
had a private show
because it's just it's joyful it's funny
and it also has a lot of heart uh and i
think just
sharing that with the world uh and
goodness
is just such a i'm so lucky i feel very
lucky that that's what i get to share
and i've
i've been waiting so i'm very excited
that it's finally
we get to share it in july and people
get to know what i've
had this dreamy look on my taste this
whole time for
but i'm like you guys have no idea what
happened in vancouver
now they'll get to know schmingadoon
welcome to our little town where friends
are
all you mean must be something they do
for tourists hey everyone
hey there pete can we go now
it rides this fine line right it's got
that real relationship
feeling and these moments we share with
our partners and spouses and then it's
got this
like spectacular inner child that comes
out and it's so
perfect in both worlds now it plays the
golden era of musicals right we are
we're in musicals here talk to me about
your favorite musicals your favorite
scenes you remember from musicals
sure um i think growing up my first
musical
ever that my grandma bought me on vhs
was oliver
which i actually watched recently i've
been showing my friend
rashida all my early favorites
um it's we laughed because i i had her
watch west side story and for some
reason
my friend was very taken by the story of
the
the bar owner or the store owner or
something but you know that's
that's what musicals do you never know
who's gonna
connect with what and so i think i loved
south pacific i loved all the colors i
had a crush on lieutenant joe cable
um and i don't know how many
eight-year-olds set a crush on
lieutenant
papers i was fine that's why we like you
so much
sesame that's why i had to end up in
schmidt
well what an unusual and exotic couple
the two you make
no wedding rings i see oh no we're not
married
definitely not really talk to me about
producing this thing so you get a call
from lorne and you go and take your time
i'm sure you took weeks to think about
working with lauren
talk to me about how that came up how
exciting that is tough decision
um if i wanted to work with him it was
you know all
the broadway video andrew at broadway
video and cinco and lauren are all
people
i obviously trust and like very much and
it was nice that they
could trust me too and because i loved
this show so much
and having such special table reads so
it was
really important that we i wanted to be
involved in making sure we got
this amazing cast and um i think i did a
pretty good job
if i had any part in it um no you
certainly did
and and you certainly have all of us
excited for for your cast mates
talk to me about the snl involvement in
this series i think it's pretty cool um
you know yeah lauren and fred
armstrong's in the cast and bowen is
writing what did it mean to
kind of have uh kind of this extended
family with you and is it just that did
you get you always feel like you have
like an extended comedy family at snl oh
definitely i mean we all
stay connected throughout the year and
um bowen's such a good friend i was so
happy he wrote on this i think
you know bowen is such a star anything
he even stands next to
gets a little of his shine um
and i loved all of the writers really
julie klausner i was so excited she was
on board for this
uh and obviously and lauren i lauren i
think has
good taste so uh you trust him as a
producer and i think it's just nice it
was nice that i got to share this with
bowen because
again it's like how do you explain
schmidt dune i haven't been able to
even like tell anybody what i what i got
to do
in the fall and so it's like i'm
bursting at the seams too for people to
see this show
it's like there's no log line that could
do this show justice you have to sit
down
and put your eyes on the screen and
watch the talent be the talent and be
crazy and wild and out there
with alan coming jane krakowski what
is this like being inside of a master
class in comedy and music every day what
is it like working with these folks
amazing fantastic um
so funny to watch so it was emotional to
want you know it's funny watching
kristen play this type of character
because it's very not christed
so it was just it was a master class and
it's
i got a show i got a show when broadway
was closed and hopefully now everybody
gets the show
i'm assuming you're not very happy with
the job that president biden is
have you doing the border if joe biden
had his way
we let everyone in talk to me a little
bit about
your future at snl we want to know are
you staying are you leaving
what can you tease us with i know i want
to know um
but i don't know yet it's sort of i
think things are a bit more
up in the air and i'm okay with that i
think last year
that's my lesson from last year is sort
of see what happens
you could end up in vancouver shooting
you know i'll be thrilled if i go back
i'll be thrilled
if that was my last show so it's sort of
i feel i feel good either way
and and i don't know yet okay all right
well talk to me about
so let's say it's a post snl life do we
see more
stuff like schmegadoon more movies more
writing what
what is the what's the next thing for
you you know it'd be fun to do
stage it'd be fun to do movies it'd be
fun to
write my own show it's sort of i'm
excited to try different things
and not um i'm excited
about the possibilities i guess you know
yes more schmidtoon anytime
ever
we're in a musical okay nobody gets
killed in a musical except oklahoma
and carousel and south pacific oh hello
west side story that's all the musicals